der Ausblick also man hat hier so das
Gefühl von
Freiheit klar ist es schöner wenn ich
drin wohne und den Blick nach außen
genieße und nicht drauf gucken
muss wir wohnen so gemütlich hier das
kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen die
reztion ist ein Paket da kommen sie
abholen Wind und Sturm ist natürlich
irgendwann
Problem dann haben die Leute halt sich
darüber beschwert dass das ganze Haus am
F vibrieren
wäre
ich habe nie in Betracht gezogen
auszuziehen wohin hier im unicenter
möchte ich werden
ja da ist natürlich viele viele
Geschichten die da passieren aber wie in
jedem anderen Dorf auch ein Wohnturm
drei Flügel mit Blick auf Dom und sieben
Gebirge fast 2000 Menschen in 968
Wohnungen auf 45 Etagen Geschäfte im
Erdgeschoss und die Öffis vor der Tür
das Vorzeigeobjekt der 70er wir
schreiben das Jahr
1973 der Architekt Werner ingendeai
läuft auf zur
Hochform das 90 Millionen teure Bauwerk
von dem man sich bei der richtfeier sehr
optimistisch eine Minderung der Not des
Wohnens versprach hat recht
ungewöhnliche Ausmaße in zwei Jahren
gebaut in 12 Monaten bezugen eine Stadt
vergleichbare Einwohnerzahl brauchte
Jahrzehnte für diese Entwicklung Wohnen
unter den Wolken wohnen in der
Vertikalen einer der das Haus in und
auswendig kennt ist Oliver Schinz wenn
ich ween soll kommen R näher an ihm muss
jeder vorbei denn klingeln gibt es im
unicenter nicht wer kommt wird
angemeldet und eingelassen von ihm denn
Oliver Schinz ist Pförtner und Mädchen
für alles man weiß nie was passiert und
es ist jeden Tag was anderes Besuch
empfangen Schlüsseldienste rufen
Handwerker koordinieren Pakete annehmen
manchmal bis zu 150 Stück am Tag dabei
war es anfangs nur ein
Aushilfsjob das ist ein Studentenjob
gewesen und später habe ich halt andere
Sachen gemacht habe hier eine
Eigentumswohnung gekauft und habe aber
nie den Kontakt zur Rezeption verloren
und hat man mich gefragt ob ich das
nicht machen könnte weil ich das ja hier
schon alles kannte und hab ich gesagt ja
eigentlich ist das eigentlich schön ich
mach das mal eine Zeit lang 34 Jahre
später ist er immer noch da jeder kennt
ihn und er kennt auch fast jeden Namen
und wohnungsnummern weiß er auswendig
und manchmal erfährt er auch mehr als
ihm lieb ist 15 da kam einer zu mir und
sagte meine Frau betrügt mich meine Frau
betrügt mich und ich habe auch gedagt
boah geh wo anders hin ne und da sagte
ich gehe jetzt hoch und spring vom
Balkon und dann habe ich den Kollegen
angerufen ich sag so und so ja ja das
sagt er immer nee nee brauch dir keine
Sorgen machen der geht nach
Hause du warst natürlich auch ne das
hilft die Zeit scheint im unicenter
steheneblieben zu sein charmant und
hässlich zugleich Schandfleck für die
einen geliebtes zu Hause für die anderen
die Rezeptur es kommt Besuch zu ihnen ja
vielen Dank danke schön es geht mit 12 m
pro Sekunde in die 30 zu einem der nie
wieder woanders leben möchte Erik Uwe
amaja der 43-Jährige wohnt seit 2011 im
unicenter selbst in einem Hochhaus groß
geworden war für ihn immer klar als ich
damals studiert habe hier in Köln da
kann ich das Haus natürlich schon und da
ich im Grunde auch ein großer New York
Fan bin war das natürlich dann
eigentlich klar dass ich irgendwann mal
auch hier in diesem Haus wohnen möchte
er zieht zunächst in eine kleinere
Wohnung im Haus letztes Jahr dann die
Gelegenheit
145 quadr er kauft für 380.000 € und
saniert ein teures Vergnügen 10 €
Hausgeld monatlich pro Quadratmeter noch
oben drauf für Instandsetzungen und
Annehmlichkeiten das ist barrierefrei
alles zugänglich wir haben die Aufzüge
man hat dann einfach so viel Service das
ist perfekt und dann auch noch
Tiefgarage Stellplatz und wenn man ganz
ehrlich ist so viele Menschen ins
besondere wenn man älter geworden ist da
wird dann ein Haus dann auch irgendwann
zur Last und es sei eine gute
Gemeinschaft im Haus ob anonym oder
nicht das könne jeder selbst entscheiden
h wohnen so viele Menschen aus den
verschiedenen Nationen aus der ganzen
Welt natürlich auch durch die vielen
Auslandsstudierenden alle Schichten von
von Arm bis reich und das ist glaube ich
das was das unicenter dann tatsächlich
dann auchch ausmacht 45 Etagen je höher
desto exklusiver nur in einem Flügel von
der ersten bis zu 25 wohnen alle gleich
denn hier vermietet das Studentenwerk an
rund 340 Studierende seit 50 Jahren
anfängliche Skepsis wenn ich wohnen
könnte wo ich wollte würde ich mir etwas
aussuchen was schön ist ne und
hier hat man es genommen weil es günstig
ist aber trotzdem fühlen sich nicht ganz
wohl
warum ja einfach weil das Haus zu groß
ist und weil man die Leute nicht kennt
man hat kein ist nichts persönliches
hier drin ne das sieht zumindest ein
Student heute ganz anders ab in die
25 Frank vontein wohnt seit einem Jahr
hier für den Student der wir inatik ein
Sechser im Lotto das Allerbeste ist dass
es immer Leute zu entdecken gibt man
trifft in den Fluren immer neue Leute
coole Leute die Lage ist auf jeden Fall
auch sehr sehr schön und einfach das
Studentenleben zu genießen hier ist
wirklich ist schon perfekt auf jeden
Fall 20 Quadrat für 290 € in direkter
Uninähe auch wenn es für ihn rein
optisch zunächst kein Highlight ist aus
wirklich schon älter aussieht auch die
Flur sind noch etwas älter mit den
teppichbüen und so aber sobald ich dann
in das Zimmer reingekommen bin und
gesehen das war neu renoviert auch
möbeliert also für mich ist es trotzdem
mein Zuhause mittlerweile schon geworden
und da kann auch die Fassade nicht viel
dran ändern also die Aussicht das macht
elich alles wieder wett egal ob Krach
oder sonst was und auch für die
Studierenden im unicenter gibt's jede
Menge Komfort drumherum
Gemeinschaftsräume wie die Waschküche
heute Menschen leer oft auch
Begegnungsstätte die Bauweise muss die
Intimsphäre des Einzelnen sichern aber
sie darf Kontakte nicht unmöglich machen
auf einen ganz Kontakt freuen sich die
meisten im unicenter denn zweimal im
Jahr ist fensterputztag am Wohnturm die
meisten Fenster lassen sich nämlich aus
Sicherheitsgründen gar nicht erst öffnen
Einsatz für das Kölner seilommando auch
für sie kein alltäglicher Job wir haben
hier eine ausstiegghöhe von 132 m und es
gibt wenig Gebäude in Köln die diese
Höhe aufweisen und das zweite ist das
unicenter ist natürlich ein Kultgebäude
für Köln Marco Saskia und Dennis seilen
sich vom Dach ab der Regen ist für das
eingespielte Team kein Problem was
tatsächlich danke
heute ein bisschen die Challenge war ist
ist der Wind der ausn von komm
Otter
hört kannst du dem Dennis noch einit
Akku mitgeben bitte ja ganz wichtig
trotz Wind dürfen sich die Seile nicht
verhädern so geht's von Fenster zu
Fenster drei Seiten mit jeweils 38
Etagen da kommt schon einiges zusammen
Stärkung umso wichtiger ja da kriegt man
schon mal auch ein Kaffee angeboten oder
oder Wasser und wir trinken den Kaffee
dann schnell im Seil und dann geht's
weiter Small Talk und nette Begegnungen
im Seil und manchmal auch Einblicke die
man lieber nicht hätte
z.B mehr wird nicht verraten der Regen
ist jedenfalls verschwunden das Seil
kommmando fertig und der Wohnturm blitzt
und blinkt
in der 37 turmetage treffen wir Sie
Helga grahen sie zieht 82 mit ihrem
mittlerweile verstorbenen Mann Peter
hier ein da war ich sofort von Anfang an
begeistert von diesen langen Fluren von
der Freiheit strahlt ja das unizenter
aus sie ziehen in den 14 doch das reicht
ihnen nicht in einem
Hochhaus da wohnt man oben und nicht
unten sonst brauchen sie ja nicht in
Hochhaus zu ziehen ne ja eigentlich
wollen sie nur ein Jahr bleiben doch 9
Jahre später ziehen sie in die oberste
Etage es ist kein langweiliges Leben das
Helga und Peter gramen im unicenter
führen er Gitarrist der Kölner Ben
Zeltinger und sie sind viel in der
Musikszene unterwegs im unicenter geht
das Partyleben dann immer
weiter wir machten uns alle ja und wir
dzen uns wir luden uns schon mal so ein
aber dann gab es auch die großen
Einladung schten uns immer viel zu
erzählen wir waren interessante Leute
und wir konnten lachen wir haben uns
Witze erzählt wir haben getanzt Hochhaus
Leben paar excellence doch es gibt auch
Dinge die man im 37 Stock nicht erleben
möchte Erinnerungen an das Erdbeben 92
mit einer Stärke von 5,9 stellt es die
Menschen im unicenter auf die Probe
mitten in der Nacht es rappelte und es
war auch laut und mein Mann sagte
Erdbeben und nahm meinen Hund nicht mich
nah meinen Hund undter Arm der Peter und
die Treppe runter und
raus das war also schon sehr
beängstigend also man kriegt so eine
leichte
panikanflug und man läuft auch ja man
rennt Treppe runter und Aufzüge und
Bewegung und versuchen dem zu entgehen
das ist dann so als würde ein Helikopter
dann äh über so ein Haus fliegen also
ist nicht nur dass S was bewegt sondern
es ist auch akustisch wahrnehmbar immer
wenn jemand anrief leuchtet dann Licht
auf dann ging das ding ding ding ding
ding das ganze Haus durch dann haben die
Leute halt sich drüber beschwert oder
gemeldet dass das ganze Haus am Fackeln
dann vibrieren wäre was es natürlich
auch muss sonst wird zusammenstürzen
also es ist auch Erdbeben sicher gebaut
hier eigentlich ein tolles Ding
erdbebensicher ein gutes Gefühl ein
Grund dafür befindet sich da wo man ihn
am wenigsten vermutet ganz weit oben in
der Spitze des
Wohnturmes Götz diegmann ist technischer
Beirat im unicenter und erklärt warum
dieser Platz so besonders ist wir sind
jetzt hier gerade im alten Heizwerk des
Hauses des unicenters von hier aus wurde
das gesamte Haus bis mit Mitte der 80er
Jahre mit Wärme
versorgt bis es dann stillgelegt wurde
die Anlage mit 3 Tonnen schweren
Heizkesseln Anfang der 70er eine
technische Innovation der Einbau eine
Herausforderung die Kessel wurden damals
mit dem Kran mit dem Baukran hier
reingestellt und dann wurden die letzten
Etagen bzw das Dach zu Ende gegossen
doch nur 10 Jahre später ist die Technik
schon
veraltet das Haus wird an Fernwärme
angeschlossen und heute 40 Jahre später
sind die Kessel immer noch da marode und
verstaubt weil man sie sehr schwer hier
oben rausbekommt und man sagt dass das
Gewicht der Kessel mit in die Statik des
Hauses eingerechnet ist wegen des
erdbebenschutzes Tonnen schwerer Stahl
der vor sich hinrottet und doch so
wichtig ist denn genau dieses Gewicht
schafft Stabilität ein Lost Place an den
sich heute nur noch selten jemand
verirrt wir fahren in die 32 Etage hier
leben Annette und Kilian dbrück zwei
eingefleischte hochhausfans kein Wunder
wächst sie doch selbst in Stuttgart im
Hochhaus auf eine schöne Kindheit und
doch sieht sie sich ständig mit
Vorurteilen
konfrontiert ist ungute Atmosphäre in so
einem
Haus ja Isolation dass man sehr für sich
ist und und keinerlei Kontakt zu den
Nachbarn hat und oft schön aus vter wer
wohnt da eigentlich in so einem Hochhaus
das ist ihnen egal seit 34 Jahren leben
sie in der maisonette wohnung im
unicenter und ziehen hier selbst eine
Tochter groß Familienleben und Hochhaus
das geht wir hatten halt auch hier das
große Glück dass sehr viele Familien
noch da waren die auch gleich alterge
Kinder hatten und dadurch sind no
Freundschaft entstanden glaub ich sogar
mal andersrum die Frage V wo anders
hinziehen als W irgendwie darüber
nachgedacht haben war unsere Tochter
nein ich will hier nicht weg das ist
mein Zuhause
aber warum gerade das unicenter wegen
eines Spielfilms der genau hier im Jahre
1975 gedreht
wurde lange bevor überhaupt klar war
dass wir jeweils nach Köln kommen haben
wir den Film gesehen die verlorene Ehre
der Katharina Blum und da war so ein
Blick auf den Dom wo ich sofort sagte zu
dir wenn Köln dann will ich da wohnen wo
ich diesen Blick habe also wir sind
beide wirklich großstadmenschen und dann
kam Köln und Hochhaus zusammen und dann
war das unicenter die Lösung und so
soll's auch bleiben denn darauf möchten
Sie nie wieder verzichten ein Tag im
unicenter geht zu Ende Helga grahen wird
abgeholt von ihren Freunden Roberto
anero und Jod Skinner aus dem 40 Stock
wahre Freundschaften im unicenter
geknüpft seit 25 Jahren seit 25
Jahren Familie ja ich bin eigentlich
auch wegen dir in unicenter eingezogen
ich habe dich am allen ersten Abend
kennengelernt Helge ist auf der Etage
war immer Helge am Anfang
fr damals noch alle auf der gleichen
Etage wohl die partyetage im unicenter
ihr ladet ja alles ein die Laden alles
was sie greifen können wenn im Aufzug
jemand nette steht wir haben heute Abend
Party kommen sie kommen sie es ist nicht
für jeden etw
we wir bleiben wohnen bis zum Ende
unserer Tage sehr gerne hier ja sehr
gerne es gibt W sonst ja wo sollen wir
hin
wohin jetzt geht's jedenfalls erstmal
gemeinsam zur B Ausstellung raus aus dem
unicenter mit dem Wissen dass es danach
wieder zurückgeht in das vertikale Dorf
mitten in Köln